yes yes it is well that's a bit of a
dead giveaway there isn't it guys
let's talk about why you need an ipad as
an architect or an architecture student
in 2020
what's going on guys my name is david
thomaj and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about why i
personally believe it is an essential to
have an ipad
or any tablet for that matter in the
architecture profession
we're going to be looking at the ipad in
three different architectural categories
today
concept client and construction each one
of these categories
has different uses and different
abilities for the ipad
which makes it such a versatile tool for
every architect or architecture student
out there in 2020.
so first of all let's talk about the
elephant in the room architects and
architecture students
print like crazy it isn't just a4 piece
of paper now and again
i'm talking hundreds of rolls of a1
paper
a2 paper thousands of scribbles and
sketches
we would go through some of the largest
amount of paper
per year per profession in my opinion so
reducing that
paper load even in the slightest is a
very
very good thing so let's talk about the
category concepts
concept is the very fundamentals of what
we do it's the very start of what we do
it's understanding our own thought
process our own ideas
and just kind of getting that down onto
the figurative paper
instead of going and jotting down
hundreds of different sketches
we now have the ability to just open up
one app
and draw draw and draw it doesn't matter
how many mistakes we make
how many times we need to go back or
change a color or change
anything we have that ability to do it
without wasting any paper we can
constantly
make new sketches and refine and fine
tune copy and paste
and kind of speed up the sketching
process in a way
there's so many times that i used to be
sketching a small idea and i'd only take
up a quarter of an a4 page
i'd never end up using the rest of that
a4 page
now i can easily open up the notes app
on an ipad
quickly sketch that idea out get it out
of my head and actually
understand it properly for myself and
more so for others
and then actually utilize that idea back
in the day it was more of a stereotype
that architects would walk around
with a hundred rolls of paper under
their arm and a huge briefcase full of
pencils
now the added benefit of being on an
ipad is the apple pencil
it doesn't have to be an ipad again it
can be any tablet
i just use the ipad because it is what i
have instead of having 100 different
pencils you can actually now
just have one you can have all your
watercolor markers all your fine liners
every single color under the sun a ruler
a compass everything you need to draw
perfectly and however you like in just
one simple compact utensil now
financially speaking buying an ipad over
using paper
isn't exactly the easiest decision ipads
can cost anywhere from 500
upwards of a thousand australian dollars
if you're looking at the ipad pro
which personally unfortunately i would
recommend
i have the ipad air and once the file
sizes get a little bit too big a little
bit too large
it gets a bit clunky and a bit slow and
the screen
isn't exactly crystal clear for the
finer details
and smaller images on the pieces of
paper
now i've done a little bit of research
here and by no means
am i a environmental expert and know
every little detail about this
but to actually understand it from a
life cycle point of view
and the carbon footprint of producing
paper versus an ipad
for the four and a half year life cycle
comparison of an ipad
is fundamentally huge so the average
office worker for example
uses 10 000 pieces of paper every single
year
like i mentioned before the architecture
profession is definitely not average we
use
way more but to be conservative we'll
stick to the 10
000 number that's generic across the
board every
500 pieces of paper produces about two
and a half kilos of co2
which means 10 000 pieces of paper
over the course of one year ends up
using
50 kilos of co2 now an ipad
to produce manufacture and utilize
and recycle throughout its whole life
cycle uses approximately 100 kilos
the life cycle of an ipad is four and a
half years
so in four and a half years you're using
100 kilos
of co2 with paper you're using 50 kilos
of co2
or you're producing 50 kilos of co2 may
i correct myself
per year eventually over that life cycle
of
four and a half years using paper you a
end up using about 225 kilos or about
125 kilos more
and you also spend 450 australian
dollars
just on paper you will need to buy 45
000 sheets of a4 paper
in four and a half years that is a lot
of wasted paper
and yes the ipad still costs more
because as we all know
nothing good for you or good for the
environment ever cost less
but you will be saving the planet in a
weird sort of roundabout way
now just because i dropped an
environmental fact in this video i'd
really appreciate it if you
smash that like button down below and
made it turn blue
you'd think it doesn't do anything but
it really really does it helps this
video
get showcased across youtube and
promotes it with the algorithm
so i'd really appreciate it if you just
hit that like button
now how does the ipad become effective
when we sit down and talk with clients
first of all if you've started using the
ipad from day one
before you've even started this project
i'm hoping everything
is on the cloud if it's not on the cloud
get it on the cloud
it's 20 20. what are you doing i'm just
going to assume that you're on the cloud
and not waste my time thinking
that you still suck on some outdated
servers
so if you are on the cloud you have the
ability to showcase your clients
every single sketch that you've done to
date
be it on a notes app on piece of paper
or whatever
if you filed and document it correctly
you can easily access that on your ipad
and show them
anywhere you don't have to carry 100
pieces of paper
like the notorious stock photo is you
just have to carry around the one tablet
you also end up using the ipad so much
for taking notes during every single
meeting
and sketching out all sorts of different
ideas and solutions
in front of the clients in order to be
able to problem solve on the fly
if you're already in the profession you
know that minutes of a meeting are very
important
so it's ideal to have something
automatically
saved and transitioned to the cloud
again
that's there permanently forever if you
aren't silly and delete it
another great benefit of having the ipad
at your disposal during a meeting with
the client
is you can easily show them renders and
3d movies
this means that you don't have to go to
your boardroom and have a meeting with
them
in a very sterile environment you can
take your clients out to lunch for
example
and talk to them about their project in
a very comfortable
unique hopefully beautiful location with
some nice food
your clients will be exceptionally happy
you'll be in a much better mood
and you'll be able to showcase them
their project
their vision and their dream wherever
you may be in the world
now with covert happening at the moment
as well a lot of people are working
remotely
or unable to meet face to face so you
now have the ability to also
quickly document everything digitally
and send it off
it means you can be anywhere in the
world working with anybody in the world
and still get your information there
very quickly
what i found is younger clients expect
you to have everything digital
middle-aged clients are kind of
reluctant at the start but they get on
board pretty quickly
and the older clients it takes a lot of
hard work
to get them on board but once they are
on board they really appreciate the fact
that this information can be conveyed to
them instantly they no longer have to
come all the way in for a meeting if
they want i don't know
a 3d render change some colors changed
they can instantly have
this information to them once it's
completed and finally
signing documentation and keeping a good
record of all
the signed documents is very important
being able to present your clients
with the ipad and all their sets of
drawings
and they can sign every single page it's
automatically filed
it's automatically stored your job is
saved it means you don't have to go back
after that meeting
scan every single page into the system
file it and then spend another hour
after the meeting
dealing with all the paperwork
everything is already done
because it's already digital lastly
construction
the construction industry is very fast
moving and fast paced
when a job is up and running things
change non-stop variations come in to
your email
24 7. so having the ability to quickly
change a set of documents flick them out
to the builder
and have them understand exactly what
needs to be done without causing any
time delays is very important by having
the ipad at your disposal
you can go to a site meeting for example
markup
what the builder is talking about if
you're working in a good office and a
big firm
you can send that back to somebody in
the office
they can quickly adjust whatever needs
to be adjusted
and potentially even send you a revised
copy
whilst you're still on site again your
information is on the cloud when you're
on site
so whatever information the builder
requires you can easily bring that up
be it pdfs of the drawing specific
details
potentially the 3d model so they can
inspect an area
or even old documentation now can you do
this
on your iphone or your samsung yes 100
you can do it on any smartphone but the
screen
is just too small to actually showcase
and be professional
there is still a very fine line between
being
professional with paper and professional
with your phone out i think having your
ipad out
taking notes on a tablet of any sort is
widely accepted nowadays whereas taking
notes on your phone
and documenting drawing on your phone
still isn't there yet
even though the phones are probably a
much more powerful and versatile tool
and in addition to all the fun facts of
having
your notes on a cloud having the ability
to use a pencil to
sign documents to take all your notes
and everything
be completely documented you have full
access to your emails
with almost a full size keyboard at your
disposal 24 7.
now i hate to break it to you if you
aren't in the profession yet
you're gonna get hundreds of emails
every single day
and it never ends but that's a good
thing it means jobs are coming in and
work is happening
what you're gonna have to do is reply to
those emails continuously and constantly
so having an ipad and being able to type
away
quickly to any email is very very handy
personally i hate typing on glass i do
like the feel of a keyboard
but when you have to it is the best
thing to use
another issue you'll find on site is
most of the jobs
that i do at least are printed on a1 or
a2 paper
if you're on a site and it's a windy or
a rainy day
and you're holding a big sheet of floppy
paper that's just smack it around in the
wind
it's gonna tear and be very difficult to
use
nine times out of ten you're either
gonna have to be inside
or somewhere away from the wind to be
able to utilize and actually read this
paper
whereas with at least one of the newer
ipads it's waterproof
you can use it outside if you want to
get a lifeproof case
even better you can do absolutely
anything
and actually just stand there with a
reasonably sized
tablet they can document and showcase
everything you've drawn
and have everybody convey that
information the only fun fact you need
to remember
is charge your ipad every single night
don't forget to charge this thing
because
unlike paper it does have a limited
battery life
you can't just pull out that paper and
discuss it for 48 hours non-stop
you will have to be in some sort of
facility where power is accessible to
you anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching the video
i hope you enjoyed it if you did make
sure you smash that like button just
down below
make it turn blue if you really enjoyed
the video and want to see more of my
content make sure you subscribe to the
channel
i usually produce a video every monday
but this week i'm trying to produce
three so wish me luck and i'll see you
next time